[Music]
unravels defining quality is how it
makes you feel nostalgic it takes you on
this journey through the life story of
an elderly woman and it does it by
transporting you into 12 pictures that
hang on the wall in her house
you don't actually play the game inside
these static pictures but instead within
the very scene where each photo was
taken somewhere along the background of
these twelve landscapes you'll find the
subjects of each photograph they're sort
of eternally suspended in their camera
poses and they're assembled in a
towering glitter of fairy lights it
looks beautiful
so it's not like real and it's not quite
supernatural either you're essentially
playing through a memory and what works
so well is how some of these memories
seem so familiar there's a memory of a
day at the seaside another is of a cold
and drizzly trip through the woods these
places and scenes they naturally sort of
kick loose some of your own memories the
ones that bury deep down in your mind
those memories you have that you
treasure those memories you have that
still hurt and those memories that you
have that do both of those things
eventually the game tells you something
really powerful about those memories now
I won't spoil what the message is and to
be honest it doesn't really work by
saying it aloud anyway but I will say
it's pretty uncommon for a game to have
such a helpful and positive thing to say
another is how dazzlingly gorgeous the
game is its depiction of life at ankle
height has impeccable attention to
detail
it's the little things quite literally
that win you over like how the moss
grows on the neglected side of a stone
bench or how the paint at the base of
banisters cracks and forms into a
brittle skin
[Music]
the audio design is even more impressive
unravel features no spoken words no
narration and developer called word
interactive has instead hinged much of
the narrative on the soundtrack
the Gamble has paid off tremendously the
aching sorrow of the violins and
panpipes the bittersweet folk music that
carries this Celtic vibe a little swells
and stirs along with you just so
wonderfully otherwise it's a fairly
standard puzzle platformer at least
mechanically the character you're
looking at now is Yanni an adorable
accident-prone panicky hero made of wool
he is useless insofar as he can't swim
or talk or punch or duck or backflip or
pretty much any other things Mario can
do as Yanni journeys through each of the
game's 12 levels his body leaves a trail
of string this is a problem because if
he walks too far he's reduced to this
gaunt wireframe eventually he can't go
any further
he's tethered to the spots he's tugging
on this remaining thread of string the
way you keep him going is by collecting
balls of wool that are scattered
throughout each world they sort of
temporarily replenish Yanni's body on
occasion you'll need to backtrack
through each level and simplify Yanni's
trail to that's in order to free up some
slack but Yanni's weakness is also his
strength his party trick is throwing a
lasso string out from his arms
spider-man style which allows him to do
all kinds of action-hero things he can
climb over rocks he can abseil down
trees he can swing across perilous
puddles of rainwater conveniently each
level is dotted with lots of wool virani
can attach his string to and thus create
a whole range of tools such as rope
bridges or trampolines most of the
game's obstacles and sadly from the
second level onwards demand a mixture of
these tools to be fashioned in the
correct order
much of unravels charm comes from how
its puzzles and indeed their solutions
are concocted from everyday items a
crushed can of cola is a couch sized
stamp a fallen tree branch is a
makeshift bobsleigh such imagination
spreads into the hazards and obstacles
to a clump of garden weeds is an
impassable thicket and there's this
field vole - I won't go into it but he
becomes your
worst nightmare but if you're curious
about unravel simply because you want to
be challenged this game will come off as
solid but unspectacular aside from a few
memorable exceptions unravels
underpinning mechanics proved to be a
bit too basic to the extent most puzzles
on particularly satisfying or at least
they're not enjoyable enough eventually
solutions can be kind of gathered just
by observing the convenient placement of
knots around you there's a lack of
pondering a lack of experimenting you're
not really stumbling into new problems
you're just going through variants of
old problems and I found that by level-5
the challenges had lost their creativity
to the extent they actually began to
outstay their welcome unravel is really
good at exposing its own problems
particularly because most levels drag on
a little longer than they should and
sometimes unravel doesn't play by its
own rules either for example the length
of your lasso occasionally stretches out
way further than you were expecting but
that's only because at that precise
moment the game needed it too even worse
the distance you can travel before your
string runs out varies wildly there's a
fair counter argument in that had
unravels stuck to the laws of physics
with scientific rigor it would probably
cease to be as fun but for a game with
physical conundrums at its core it needs
at the very least to be consistent with
its own laws you play unravel long
enough a tiny but noticeable distrust
will have built between you and the game
especially since everything else works
so well unravel is a gorgeous storybook
adventure a tale of a doll brought to
life who travels through the faded
memories of his owner but assessed
purely on gameplay it's a bit like Yanni
himself it's alluring and pleasant just
not quite robust enough
[Music]
you
you